boulder's gate 3 is almost upon us i'm
sure i've said that a few times already
anyway it's for real real this time
since its announcement back at e3 2019
we've been drip fed information about
the return
of the legendary franchise so it's hard
to get a clear picture of what to expect
so in the lead up to its early access
launch i've put together a handy recap
of all the things you need to know
before you jump into baldur's gate three
alright so what will be in the early
access
well this is just step one of the game's
development according to larian they
have boasted that even in early access
it'll have a complete narrative
adventure
full tutorial 600 characters 146 spells
and actions
80 combat instances a crime and
consequence system to hold you chaotic
evil folks accountable
twitch and stadium audience interaction
four player online multiplayer eight
races six classes
and over 20 hours of gameplay that's a
lot of nitty-gritty detail
but what makes it appealing is that it
all feeds into player choice and agency
that is designed to be at the core of
the experience even when you've worked
your way through a run of the early
access offerings there's enough content
diversity to enable multiple different
runs
with multiple characters and multiple
actions hopefully meaning your
playthrough will be different from your
prior runs
and also any others you may hear about
from your friends this early access
experience is also supposedly pretty
dense
bigger even than the original early
access release of divinity original sin
2.
if you want a direct comparison dos 2
had 22 combat encounters versus baldur's
gate 3's
80. original sin 2 had 17 600 voice
lines when it went into early access
compared to bg3 having over 45 000
dos 2's 142 early access characters
versus bg 3's 600
and divinity original sin 2 had a nice
69 spells and actions when it became
first playable
while baldur's gate 3 has 146. now
considering i put over 160 hours into
divinity original sin 2 once it hit
version 1.0
i'm sure there will be plenty to keep us
occupied from the early access version
of baldur's gate 3
and all through its development you
don't need to have played the original
boulder's gate 1 and 2 to understand
what's going on in boulder's gate 3. but
honestly i do recommend them
because they're still pretty great
although from what we've been told the
story of baldur's gate 3
is built off the back of what happened
in baldur's gate 1 and 2.
and if you want a reminder of what that
was you can click the button in the top
right corner
where i recapped the story of both of
them however
while the story will touch on some of
the elements of one and two in some ways
that
old school players will resonate with
and there may be some familiar returning
characters
that's not likely to become apparent
until deeper into the game
which could be outside of what we get to
experience in bg3's early access
so it sounds like there will be some
delicious tidbits of lore for long time
fans of the series to get kick out of
but nothing so deep that it'll be
off-putting for folks that are new to
the franchise
after all boulder's gate 3 is not a
direct sequel to the exploits of
gorion's ward that came out nearly 20
years ago but instead sounds like a
continuation of the world of baldur's
gay and the stories
that are within its setting things like
years and time
are pretty vague concepts in dungeons
and dragons but it's also worth noting
that baldur's gate 3
takes place in the current setting of
the forgotten realms
that means the world we will be
exploring in the early access release is
over 100 years
after boulder's gate 2 shadow of arm but
with all those years between stories who
could be returning from previous games
well we've already seen volo alive and
seemingly well
apparently being trapped in an
imprisonment spell for a whole century
hasn't really had too much of a negative
impact on the lad and remember we are in
the world of dungeons and dragons
where spells ageless elves magical
artifacts
and machinations are aplenty if larian
wants a reason for another companion or
character to be alive and appear in the
game
they'll have plenty of lore to tap into
to make it happen
and if you're curious about the fan
favorite minsk and boo and their
whereabouts in particular
well about 40 years after baldur's gate
2 they were petrified into a village
statue where they stood for
approximately 80 years until a magical
surge freed them from their bronze
prison the berserker and the miniature
space hamster have been adventuring ever
since
so fingers crossed we get to go for the
eyes with those guys
if you want to get a better feel for the
world without playing the classic games
from nearly 20 years ago though
the books wikis videos and forums
surrounding the latest edition of dnd
will be overflowing with lore that will
no doubt tap into baldur's gate 3.
as for rules though baldur's gate 3 is
built around larian's own interpretation
of the 5th edition of dungeons dragons
now what that means is that it has a lot
of the fun bells and whistles that 5v
uses
like its dual wielding inspiration
points its suite of magic items monsters
etc but larian have recognized that not
everything translates well from
a pen and paper tabletop role-playing
game to a huge crpg
based in the same world so instead of
sticking strictly to 5e
boulder's gate 3 exists in a middle
ground where the rules are similar
enough to the dungeons and dragons many
of you may know
and love but are also malleable enough
to create a distinct virtual experience
that's full of choice and fresh
opportunities
like i said if you want to get
acquainted about the world in which
boulder's gate 3 is set
and theorize what it might grow into i
think that reading any of the 5th
edition dnd books or wikis can't be a
bad place to start
and as someone who has played a few real
life table top dungeons and dragons
campaigns
it's been pretty fascinating to watch
what i've learned and had my dungeon
master throw at me come to life
in the previews of baldur's gate 3.
the mind flayers are the main enemy of
you and your companions in baldur's gate
3.
these lovecraftian horrors steal you
away and infect your brain
with a special kind of tadpole in the
opening moments of the game
they've appeared in many of the advanced
dungeons and dragons video games
most notably baldur's gate 2 depicted as
closed away in their own den protecting
an
elder brain and in the drow city found
in the underdark
they are some of the strongest entities
in the dungeons and dragons universe
dominating the minds of lesser beings
and turning them into subservient slaves
previously they used to rule the astral
plane but fled to the underdark when the
gethyanki threatened to exterminate them
we see them as a shell of their former
selves at a fraction of their strength
in the boulder's gate 3 opening
cinematic it seems that the mind flayers
are in desperate times
forcing them to directly attack the city
in an effort to restore their empire
now the aforementioned tadpole inside
your brain is what usually causes
victims to transform into mind flayers
as part of a process called
ceremorphosis however like i said this
tadpole
is special so there's a little more
going on with you and your party
what special means or how special this
brain grub is though
we don't quite know yet either way if
these mind flayers are anything like
that tabletop counterparts expect them
to be some of the toughest sneakiest
most manipulative
and interesting opponents in boulder's
gate 3
that is whenever we get to meet them
while fans are no doubt wondering when
we will see the titular city
of boulder's gate thus far everything
we've seen has showcased the lands
deeper into faerun
as well as much more bizarre locations
like the underdark and the hellish
realms of avernus
if we look back to the very first
boulder's gate game there was
hours upon hours of content to play
through before you crossed the bridge
and
finally made it to the city so i
wouldn't be surprised if it's the same
in boulder's gate 3.
given how iconic the location is it
makes sense that larian would want to
build up anticipation
so that the first visit to baldur's gay
is all the more exciting
we've already seen a great deal of
diversity in the world which serves as a
pretty tantalizing tease for what the
future holds
as the game develops it's also worth
thinking about how dense and huge a city
like baldur's gate could be
something so large and imposing with so
many people shops stalls and stories
is no doubt a massive undertaking for
the team to create
so as it stands although the early
access should provide interesting areas
to explore we have no definitive answer
on when we'll be able to breach
boulder's gates i serve the flaming fist
laryn has said that the team expect the
journey from original early access
release on october 6th
to the full 1.0 version to take around a
year
but i think it would be smart to add a
few months onto that estimate
considering the boulder's late release
schedule shifts we've
seen so far after all game development
is hard and early access timelines are
meant to be
pretty fluid but this isn't larian's
first foray into the world of early
access
the team has previously said that this
model has made their games become better
end
products and as iterations of the game
release over the coming months
players will be able to track its growth
as well as be part of the feedback
process
which larian tends to be quite
responsive to i can just say for those
of you who are choosing to wait and sit
on their dice until the final build
i pray that the journey will be swift
and fruitful
at the recording of this video we are
just a few days away from boulder's gate
3 launching
so we're about to shift our focus on to
what the game contains
rather than all this theorizing we've
been doing over the past year or so
i will be covering the heck out of
boulder's gate 3 right here on gamespot
from the early access version through to
its iterations and finally its 1.0
release
so if you don't want to miss any of that
then make sure you subscribe
to gamesbot.com
[Music]
you